[Music]
in 1956 architect Frank Lloyd Wright
proposed a mile-high skyscraper it was
going to be the world's tallest building
by a lot five times as high as the
Eiffel Tower but many critics laughed at
the architect arguing that people would
have to wait hours for an elevator or
worse that the tower would collapse
under its own weight most engineers
agreed and despite the publicity around
the proposal the Titanic tower was never
built
but today bigger and bigger buildings
are going up around the world firms are
even planning skyscrapers more than a
kilometer tall like the Jeddah Tower in
Saudi Arabia three times the size of the
Eiffel Tower
very soon Wright's mile-high miracle may
be a reality so what exactly was
stopping us from building these mega
structures 70 years ago and how do we
build something a mile high today in any
construction project each story of the
structure needs to be able to support
the stories on top of it the higher we
build the higher the gravitational
pressure from the upper stories on the
lower ones this principle has long
dictated the shape of our buildings
leading ancient architects to favor
pyramids with wide foundations that
support lighter upper levels but this
solution doesn't quite translate to a
city skyline a pyramid that tall would
be roughly one and a half miles wide
tough to squeeze into a city center
fortunately strong materials like
concrete can avoid this impractical
shape and modern concrete plans are
reinforced with steel fibres for
strength and water reducing polymers to
prevent cracking the concrete in the
world's tallest tower
Dubai's Burj Khalifa can withstand about
8,000 tons of pressure per square meter
the weight of over 1,200 African
elephants of course even if a building
supports itself it still needs support
from the ground without a foundation
buildings this heavy would sink fall or
lean over
to prevent the roughly half a million
ton tower from sinking 192 concrete and
steel supports called piles were buried
over 50 meters deep the friction between
the piles and the ground keeps this
sizeable structure standing besides
defeating gravity which pushes the
building down a skyscraper also needs to
overcome the blowing wind which pushes
from the side on average days wind can
exert up to 17 pounds of force per
square meter on a high-rise building as
heavy as a gust of bowling balls
designing structures to be aerodynamic
like China's sleek Shanghai Tower can
reduce that force by up to 1/4 and wind
bearing frames inside or outside the
building can absorb the remaining wind
force such as in Seoul's Lotte Tower but
even after all these measures you could
still find yourself swaying back and
forth more than a meter on top floors
during a hurricane to prevent the wind
from rocking tower tops many skyscrapers
employ a counterweight weighing hundreds
of tons called a tuned mast damper the
Taipei 101 for instance has suspended a
giant metal orb above the 87th floor
when wind moves the building this orb
sways into action absorbing the building
is kinetic energy as its movements trail
the towers hydraulic cylinders between
the ball and the building convert that
kinetic energy into heat and stabilize
the swaying structure with all these
technologies in place our mega
structures can stay standing and stable
but quickly traveling through buildings
this large is a challenge in itself
in Wright's age the fastest elevators
moved a mere 22 km/h thankfully today's
elevators are much faster traveling over
70 km/h with future cabins potentially
using frictionless magnetic rails for
even higher speeds and traffic
management algorithms group riders by
destination to get passengers and empty
cabins where they need to be
skyscrapers have come a long way since
Wright proposed his mile-high Tower what
were once considered impossible ideas
have become architectural opportunities
today it may just be a matter of time
until one building goes the extra mile
how do engineers ensure that these
massive structures don't come down in an
earthquake
check out this lesson and learn why it's
not the sturdiest buildings but the
smartest that remains standing
[Music]